you didn't see me
but here i am beastmaster64
it's been 18 months
18.
there's a pewdiepie right there i've
infiltrated his office
i've killed all kinds of [ __ ] pokemon
dogs i ate a chihuahua at once but if
there's one thing i never hunted
it's a youtuber i'm not gonna just hunt
some second level piece of [ __ ] youtuber
like
jacksepticeye no oh no
i'm on the hunt for the pewdiepie the
greatest goddamn youtuber of all time
love his channel but he needs to die
i'm not just gonna kill pewdiepie i'm
gonna
eat his [ __ ] tonight i'm not just
gonna kill pewdiepie
i'm gonna challenge him then i'll kill
him i'm gonna beat him
just like a kill jacksepticeye i'm gonna
challenge him
in a duel then i'll kill him have you
ever heard of
leafy more like
that's him now what did that say to talk
back to me
playing you're a plane you're going to
be tonight for that
[Music]
ah you got that mirror
i love you like you were my father i
based my whole career after
this man i wish i could call you daddy
can i call you daddy
snake please snake snake
snaker please
why are we still here
just to suffer every night
i can feel my leg the first thing you've
been bothering me is for too [ __ ]
long
these [ __ ] lights don't turn up
oh jesus christ the [ __ ] is are they me
oh
oh i missed that's impossible
i never missed a shot in my life from
that close holy [ __ ]
he's nearby his being in his office
affects my skills
he's there
that's [ __ ] right
[Music]
am i getting in trouble for this 360.
do you think it will go through the roof
because there's people walking upstairs
ah that's concrete
hell yeah i'm not going to jail [ __ ] is
that a [ __ ] water bottle
wait i hit it it's leaking
look at this oh yeah
got him
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine
face master but
[Music]
hey pewdiepie nice to finally
meet you just get that i challenge you
to a shoot-off
whoever wins gets to destroy what the
other person loves the most
this guy
if i win i get to shoot your
50 million thing whatever i don't care
and i get to kill you if you win you get
the most prized possession in the entire
universe it has been with me
since i was born oh oh okay
hello that's right it's home [ __ ]
then best started
[Music]
if you're gonna be a plant then just
shut the [ __ ] up you're a plan
no one watches for you anymore he hates
when i said that
why don't you take a three three days
break
he went on a three days break he made a
video saying he's going on a prank
and you were away for how long three
days
three [ __ ] days this is how you do
what he called dude
let's not fire towards the glass anymore
i should definitely not have a gun
oh
perfect you call that a gun
here we go my first show
steady as a rabbit bert
oh being on the cross wasn't enough of a
rough time
now you've been shot in the dick perfect
round two and had tommy
whoa 10 friends
japan time for number two baby this
banana
it's gonna go banana okay
all right here we go
just got it
i never killed a banana before
is it morally correct
who am i to judge if a banana lives or
dies
i suppose we all go to hell anyway
i mean if i miss that i'd be pretty [ __ ]
i'm
i've got him
is he right there that's the penis of
the banana
perfect round three
oh yeah
japan last shot if i get this one right
you die for the pie
damn i won't that's what i want
but i must confirm the kill
whoa
you win
[Music]
be right back imma kill what you love
quick
now i get to destroy the 50 million and
then i'm going to destroy you
because i'm beef smashed 64.
ah
what's this your own gun
want a piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
now it's time for the real pewdiepie's
over party
[Music]
cause
in what you say
you